les nappes d'algues brunes étouffe le
plan d'eau et la plage excepté cette
zone délimitée par ce barrage long de
800 mètres
ils étaient installés de façon à
protéger les rivages et la zone de
baignade deux complexes hôteliers de
punta cana les sargasses sont en ce
moment le cauchemar de cette région du
sud est de la république dominicaine à
la croisée de la mer des caraïbes et de
l'océan atlantique
cette zone est considérée sur le clan au
touristiques comme la poule aux oeufs
d'or
cette barrières flottantes imaginées et
mises au point par des français pourrait
atténuer l'impact sur le tourisme
hôteliers
on a fini le prototypage maintenant on
est dans le dans la partie
commercialisation c'est à dire que les
produits qu'on va vendre à partir de
maintenant ce sont ces produits là qui
sont aboutis l'élément important dans la
mise en place de ce barrage et le
mouillage
ici les flotteurs et le filet sont
amarrés tous les trois ou six mètres
afin de les maintenir en place et qu'ils
puissent résister aux différentes
pressions et tensions causées par les
courants la houle le vent et les
sargasses ans s'est rendu compte que les
algues intentions derrière la barrière
sur ne les enlève pas il ya des tonnes
et des tonnes d'algues et y flotte avec
les cours avec le vent ça pousse sur la
barrière et donc ça va la détruire parce
que il ya cette masse importante
donc on s'est dit il faut développer une
main une barge pour récolter la barrière
la sargasse
[Musique]